they're similar we were able to record
demotion captions on stage which we did
know a lot of the developments and
motion capture aren't really applicable
to us but I know that too with some of
the other films that we have done you
know the apparently age films being a
case the big thing that they then moved
on from being able to motion capture on
the sit as motion capture twenty twenty
actors at the same time all a motion
capture suits on the set that was a next
big thing that they heard all that had
to be crossed is how because you got all
these motion capture cameras and you've
got people performers and suits with all
these dots and so all the cameras is
like they're recording 20 different
people and they've got to figure out
these dots of who that belongs to this
person and that most of it belongs to
that person you know the computer has to
actually work out who the hell you know
you know it has to be able to to
differentiate between the different
individuals and and so I think we're
we've had 40 50 people on stage at times
now you don't being motion captured all
at the same time there's a number of
effects right I mean you know this this
strike who's a you know digital creation
but we brought all the experience that
we had from you know working with an
actor in the key role on set like we did
with Andy on on rings with Gollum we
went into production with Shrike with
the design that isn't as design we got
it to a point that you know with a lot
of pressure to get shooting and you know
we knew you it's gonna be you know this
height he was gonna be sort of robotic
was sort of part man and we kind of got
to this point where it was yeah okay
look that's good enough for us to shoot
words we're gonna have Steven on said in
the suit and that's fine but let's we've
got to keep going and it wasn't until we
finished shooting then we started seeing
Stevens performance and we're like well
that's never gonna translate to that
design we should have been a bit more
wiser but you know as part of the
process it would be something that we
could then address and we did and we we
then went through the process of
designing Shrike around Stevens you know
face and his performance you know but he
was tricky because he he wasn't like an
animal that we could take reference from
and he wasn't just a robot that we could
make Ignite mechanized he had to be a
blend of the two and he had to be an
interesting design that we you know
that we took that was different to
terminator or Robocop or things that
we've seen before we had to give him a
zone aesthetic in his own character and
make him very human yet threatening and
you know robotic and relentless at the
same time in history I histor Skaar as a
digital makeup and we had a prosthetic
which was sort of very fine but it was
as far as we could push makeup but we
wanted her to be disfigured we wanted to
have this gouge through her face and so
we actually had to do that digitally to
create the actual indication that you
couldn't naturally do there's the way he
used to be able to do it with makeup
which was you'd paint Claudian on the
skin and that would actually shrink the
skin and it would like you know that
actually would disfigure you and it's
really bad for your skin and there's
actors that used to use it that have
skin issues now so it's illegal and you
shouldn't use it but and we weren't
gonna do that to Hera so you know so
we've we know we did that digitally I
don't know today honestly couldn't tell
you if we what if we wrote anything far
more Rangers we tend to usually write
something because it's often it's
simulation software - it's some
simulation meaning you know if you um if
you've got a pile of dust on on the
table and you and you you and you fan it
with your hand
you know that says you've got to
simulate the wind blowing on the dust
and it's sort of it you know it's a
simulating the natural world and so this
is a lot of simulation and in this movie
because of the vehicles are movement
they all create dust they all you know
squash the ground threat because it's so
heavy and so they're interacting with
the environment all the time which you
know you've got to create a simulation
software so it wouldn't surprise me if
they wrote simulations and when they're
always writing software I am yeah look
I'm not a computer guy I don't actually
don't really understand much about how
how any of it works but um yeah good on
them the city's probably are one of the
most difficult aspects because the fact
of everything's moving it really throws
it out when you start moving the ground
and so we sort of actually approached
some of it in a bit of an old-fashioned
way of just hand modeling everything
does it all had to be animatable to move
which usually you don't have to do with
the environments you can build them set
them in place and just let the
simulations run but we
we had to move out through space so it
created a whole lot of separate problems
because they're not used to having the
layouts that are usually fixed to be in
motion when I investigate it and they
read the books I thought well you're
never gonna be able to pull that off you
know at the scale of it the scale of the
cities you know you know rumbling over
the earth yeah I thought that's that
you're never gonna be able to create
that scale on screen so that's what
stuck out to me was that it was going to
be impossible to achieve and yeah and
here we are
[Music]